with the return of Deadpool's Wade
Wilson comes a whole new set of faces
that will join the hero in his fight
against evil in Deadpool - and a new
standout has taken the internet by storm
meet Peter played by Rob Delaney on the
surface peter is your average
middle-aged dude but it seems that what
he lacks in superpowers he makes up for
with enthusiasm Rob Delaney may be a new
face in the comic book movies but this
isn't his first rodeo let's take a
closer look at why Peter from Deadpool 2
looks so darn familiar you're in
funniest person on Twitter back before
Twitter expanded its character limit
from 140 to 280 Delaney regularly used
the social media platform to workshop
material bringing witty quips and
humorous observations to the Internet
before it was the fashionable thing to
do
in 2012 Delaney became the first person
to be named the funniest person on
Twitter at Comedy Central's Comedy
Awards Delaney explained to social media
success - Mashable saying don't work too
hard on a tweet when you see people
trying to for example synthesize to
current news stories into one clever
tweet it can get pretty clunky and their
labor is obvious rendering their tweet
unfunny published author
in 2013 Delaney released a memoir titled
Rob Delaney mother wife sister human
warrior Falcon darts dick turbid cabbage
while the book featured its fair share
of dad humor and fart jokes Delaney also
used the medium to explore his very real
struggles with depression and alcohol
addiction a decade before he honed his
craft online he was regularly bobbing on
stage and he made a habit of getting
blackout drunk with his book Delaney
returns to the rock bottom moments that
help shape the man he's become
Delaney told the LA Times it was a
memoir that paid no attention to
chronology and was just about memories
that surfaced in my own sort of psyche
because I figured those would be the
ones that would be most interesting to
people yeah I drove into a building in
LA and broke both my arms and was in
jail in a wheelchair standup according
to an interview with good men project
Delaney's life changed in 2009 after he
was arrested for driving under the
influence he got sober and about
year later he began seriously pursuing
stand-up comedy
the comedian explained honesty is the
main ingredient I mean you must be funny
but certainly the funniest stuff will
always be the most honest no secret
there Delaney has since played shows all
over the country and eventually landed
his own 2013 comedy special Rob Delaney
live at the Bowery Ballroom now if you
see someone with a neck tattoo you know
that they got it at their local muffin
shop they got like a Frappuccino neck
tattoo special TV rolls over the years
Delaney has continued racking up credits
both behind and in front of the camera
for a short time he had a project in the
works at Comedy Central called
at Rob Delaney which unfortunately never
saw the light of day as he continued
flexing his comedic muscles Delaney
found himself graduating from the
confines of the internet and eventually
landing in the posh arena of primetime
network television appearing in shows
like Cougar Town and burnin love the
funny man also appeared in multiple
sketches on Comedy Central's key & peele
with his standout performance being the
campaign advisor character catastrophe
in 2014
Delaney relocated his family to the UK I
love it I love living there and their
teeth are a mess according to the Los
Angeles Times just one year after
settling into his new home the hit
series catastrophe premiered on
Britain's channel 4 and soon after
Amazon Prime's streaming platform the
Emmy nominated BAFTA winning series is
co-created and co-written by the lady
and Sharon Morgan Thank You Sharon
Horgan for teaching me how to write
comedy I did stand-up I can tell a joke
but not make a show thank you not only
did the series disrupt the rom-com
formula with a pleasant amount of
vulgarity throughout the realistic
subject matter came at audiences with a
brutal sense of honesty seldom seen on
the small screen Variety reported back
in 2016 that the streaming service
renewed catastrophe through its fourth
season UK star one of the perks of being
the funniest person on Twitter is the
global audience that the platform
provides once delaney relocated to
Britain his star only continued to rise
in between his time as a full-time
comedian TV star and writer Delaney has
made a habit of appearing on a
full of British panel shows a popular
type of gameshow that throws celebrities
into the mix throughout his experience
doing stand-up comedy and pontificating
on pop culture online Delaney has proven
himself to be a worthy competitor thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]